ja das ist nicht einmal aussprechen die
müssen immer dazwischen dann aber
wirklich Unsinn ist
ein großer Unterschied
sagen Lauterbach kann das einfach mal
sagen es ist ein falsches Wort
verlässt die Sendung glaube ich ja das
ist sehr schade bleiben Sie bei uns nein
natürlich sehr schade für unsere Runde
da es geht hier in dieser Sendung und
dafür das muss ich ihn liebe zuschauen
und Zuschauer sagen ganz klar darum dass
wir hier eine offene Debatte führen dass
hier jeder sagen kann was er denkt
gerade das Thema der Pandemie ist ein
hoch emotionales Thema ganz ganz viele
Menschen haben gelitten und ich glaube
wir müssen alle daran arbeiten da
transparent zu werden und da auch
aufzuklären und genau das soll hier in
dieser Sendung auch passieren deswegen
finde ich es persönlich besonders schade
wenn jemand nicht mehr Teil dieser
Diskussion sein möchte das Respektieren
ich hoffe meine gestern trotzdem
weiterhin Freude daran diese Debatte
weiterzuführen